what up space fam goals in here from
anime uproar back at it again to discuss
one piece i've had many requests to
update my all mythical zones video in
light of recent hype events in the story
so here i am to update the most hyped
category of devil fruits not only will i
be updating some existing entries since
we got more information about them i'll
also be adding two mythical zones to the
list including the most hyped devil
fruit of all time so make sure to stay
tuned for that i also published a more
general all zone users in their powers
explained video before which you can
check out as well link in the
description but this one will be a more
updated version for mythical zones in
particular if you do enjoy these
one-piece videos especially these longer
ones and want to keep them coming the
best thing you could do is channel the
power king within and smash that like
button with no mercy if you haven't make
this the video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and if you're new to
the nakama let me know by saying hi
below in the comments and leaving your
favorite mythical zone fruit lastly
while you wait for the next one piece
video to drop feel free to check out my
huge growing one piece playlist that
includes videos on all the yonko
warlords and many more the full playlist
can be found in the description now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all let's start things off
with one of blackbeard's 10 titanic
commanders crescent moon hunter katarina
devin she ate the inuinu no me model qb
no kitsune for pokemon and naruto fans
it's pretty much the nine-tailed fox
fruit and in the viz manga it is called
the dog dog fruit mythical type model
nine-tailed fox devin is 36 years old
after the time skip and her current
bounty is unknown but we do know that
she's a whopping 11 foot 10 inches tall
or 361 centimeters she can use her fruit
to transform into a nine-tailed fox and
perhaps more interestingly she can use
the power to transform herself into
anyone and impersonate them during
chapter 925 we saw the fruit in action
when she used it against gekkomoria
tricking the latter into thinking that
absalom was still alive she does
transform back after it's revealed that
absalom is dead and that shiryu stole
his clearclear fruit it's the best fruit
for disguising yourself as someone else
because it allows the user to transform
their clothes as well unlike the clone
clone fruit that covers devon and the
nine-tailed fox fruit for now we haven't
seen a lot of it so far but we're sure
to learn more about this interesting
mythical fruit as the story progresses
for number two we got the corrupted
shogun of wano kurozumi orochi and his
heavy hebinomi model yamatano orochi
another fruit that might remind you of
naruto specifically of orochimaru its
english name is the snake snake fruit
model yamata no orochi and it's based on
an eight-headed serpent-slash-dragon in
japanese mythology this fruit lets
oroshi transform into a giant
eight-headed serpent we've seen that
orochi can easily grab and trap a person
within the jaws of one of his serpent
heads having eight heads also lets you
attack multiple people at once which is
useful the fruit as many of us predict
it also lets you survive being beheaded
one mythical parallel of yamata no
orochi is the hydra in hercules and most
of us may remember that cutting off one
of its heads never did the trick in fact
in that example multiple heads would
grow back to replace the first at one
point kaido beheads orochi which wasn't
that surprising after all why would such
a strong figure want to keep someone as
annoying cowardly and proud as orochi
around longer than necessary later
orochi recovered somehow and then ran
into the red scabbards fukurokuju
informed him that the red scabbers
didn't even know that he'd already died
once at kairo's hand what might have
been a crazy reveal to them ended up
being an anticlimactic but hilarious
revenge after uroshi transformed into
his eight-headed form and arrogantly
talked about how he would finish off the
injured red scabbards the scabbards went
on to slice off all of his heads
effortlessly commenting on how they have
no time to waste on the likes of hirochi
now this is as far as we got when i
dropped the previous mythical zones
video at that point we weren't 100 sure
orochi would survive having all of his
heads taken off but i mentioned it
wouldn't be surprising if he did
considering his mythical zone fruit and
as if to not disrespect a mythical zone
oda did in fact have orochi survive even
those malty beheadings it seems like
huntress flame finally took him out in
the latest chapter and for him to
finally die hiyori had to neutralize his
mythical zone power with the help of sea
prism stone nails in the end the yamata
no rochi is a very interesting fruit
with unique abilities like most mythical
zone fruits i honestly don't even know
what if anything would have killed him
if he or he didn't neutralize his fruit
powers but cool fruits don't always go
to cool or even strong characters and
this is one of those times although i
found the fruit fascinating oroshi
himself was definitely not worthy of the
mythical fruit for number three let's
look at a character who is definitely
worthy of his mythical zone fruit dr
marco the phoenix marco is as legendary
as yonko commanders come he was the
right hand man to whitebeard the man
called the strongest in the world and
the closest to the one piece he is
currently 45 years old and his birthday
is in october like mine coincidence i
think not he's six foot eight inches
tall which is almost like me like a bit
taller but almost like me and his bounty
is
1.374 billion berries a bounty bigger
than queen's impressive bounty of 1.32
billion berries so even among yonko
commanders his bounty is top tier
although since the last video it was
revealed that king actually had a higher
bounty at 1.39 billion how crazy is it
that an injured zorro beat a dude with a
higher bounty than marco absolutely
insane to think how far our crew has
come and yeah people will be like bro
it's not all about bounty you can't
determine strength based off of solely
bounty and i know but you can't just
ignore the hype around bounties either
i'm just saying of course marco the
phoenix has the phoenix fruit more
specifically the toritorino me model
phoenix or the berg bird fruit model
phoenix another way to translate it is
as immortal bird another hype detail
about the mythical fruit back in chapter
553 we first saw marco use his ability
and it was to deflect an admiral's
attack no less without breaking a sweat
marco's fruit allows him to adopt the
properties of a phoenix or to straight
up fully transform into a blue phoenix
marco's blue flames allow him to heal
himself or others this is one of the
reasons that the immortal bird
translation is so apt because marco can
seemingly heal from otherwise lethal
wounds using blue flames it's like an
enhanced logia because marco can take
hits as if they just went through him
but in his case he could also use the
blue flames to heal from haki infused
attacks as well as mentioned marco could
block admiral kizuru's attack and he
also successfully blocked admiral
akainu's attack as well during the
paramount war and he would later have no
lasting damage showing just how superior
this fruit is to ace's flame flame fruit
which was easily defeated by akainu he
was able to use his fruit for a while to
also hold his own while fighting against
king and queen at the same time two
yonko commanders with both confirmed
bounties over a billion berries
obviously this doesn't mean he could
actually beat them both at the same time
and perospero pointed out that he looked
exhausted but it's still very impressive
considering how good of a fighter marco
is in battle it's all the more
impressive that he can be just as
helpful when it comes to healing others
he's used his flames to help heal others
and more specifically he's used them as
a way to help prevent the further spread
of queen's virus in many people notably
marco's flames won't burn you as they
burn like conventional flames but they
can definitely be used to reinforce the
power of his attacks so the op power
comes with both offensive defensive and
healing capabilities notably oda has
told us that marco's healing has
limitations in a question corner so he's
not necessarily immortal in his phoenix
form it's quite likely that if marco
drains all his stamina he won't be able
to use his healing powers which might
explain why he sometimes leaves minor
wounds like scratches or bruises
unhealed in battle another way that
marco could definitely be killed is if
you exposed him to sea stone then he
won't be able to use his regeneration on
mortal wounds it should be said that
marco's forces fought against
blackbeard's forces in the payback war
about a year after the paramount war and
marco's side was obliterated even so
marco made it out fine without suffering
lasting wounds thanks to his phoenix
powers but i think that's enough about
marco for the purposes of this video his
mythical fruit is one of my favorites
and though it has its limits it's let
marco at the very least exchange blows
with many of the best fighters in the
world without taking any lasting damage
next up we have kaido the leader of the
beast pirates and the man called the
strongest creature in the world kaido's
bounty is over 4.6 billion berries
meaning among the living yonko he has
the highest bounty but probably not for
long as we'll get into later on in the
video so the question was for a long
time what exact devil fruit did kaido
have what mythical zone is worthy of
going to the leader who stands at the
apex of the animal kingdom that is the
beast pirates there were theories that
did a straightforward dragon fruit even
theories that he was a dragon who had a
kind of human fruit but during chapter
999 big mom revealed that on the day rox
fell into ruin at god valley she gave
kaido a legendary model of the fish fish
fruit and she even says because of that
kaido owes her his life that's how big
of a favor this fruit was in her view
the official name for the legendary
mythical fish fish fruit was given to us
in a data book and it was the
me model serio or the fish fish fruit
model seru the serio is an azure dragon
and if this at first confuses you how a
fish fish fruit can turn into a dragon
just think of magikarp and gyarados in
pokemon gyarados 2 is based off of the
japanese series which is in turn based
off of a chinese myth specifically
there's a chinese dragon gate myth where
there is a giant waterfall and if a carp
is able to persevere and make it all the
way to the top of the practically
impossible to climb waterfall it will
become a dragon i'd like to think that
kaido's dragon form is a sign that he
was skilled enough and worked hard
enough to awaken the fruit and usually
the user of this fruit starts off as a
kind of weak magikarp rather than a
majestic dragon this isn't confirmed and
if it does start off as a magikarp fruit
then the question arises can it allow
its users to actually swim despite the
usual devil fruit curse but that's a
topic for a completely different video
and back to the question if this is a
fitting fruit for the world's strongest
creature it definitely seems to be since
eastern dragons like this one were often
considered to be extremely powerful and
were even worshiped as gods it's almost
like we'd need another godly fruit to
take down such a powerful fruit user but
back to kaido's specific powers we often
see him transform into his oswara dragon
form and more or less recently we've
even got to see his hybrid form which is
accompanied by a very cool tale overall
i really like the aesthetics of his
hybrid form up to very recently kaido's
dragon form was the biggest zone
transformation we've seen and in this
form he absolutely dominates the skyline
when he's flying overhead his dragon
form is so big and powerful that it
stated he could obliterate all of cody
if he thrashes about in a drunken stupor
while in his dragon form thus without
even trying to he could destroy an
entire region of a country the insane
durability of his mythical scales has
also been noted multiple times during
chapter 923 luffy hit kaido many times
with hockey enhanced attacks and
although they landed and looked painful
kaido got up unscathed like absolutely
nothing happened and went on to take out
luffy with one blow it's also been said
about kaido's fruit that it gives kaido
access to more supernatural abilities
than any other mythical zone we've seen
so far although i feel like the newest
revealed mythical zone will probably
give it a run for its money one such
ability is that he can create flame
clouds that for all intents and purposes
allow him to fly and can even lift up an
entire island and turn it into a flying
castle additionally kaido has been seen
launching devastating fire blasts from
his mouth in dragon mode and hybrid mode
and the list goes on this truly godlike
creature has turned his roar into
lightning he has released blades of wind
strong enough to cut off a red
scabbard's arm and he's been able to
summon multiple tornadoes which led to
zorro labeling him a natural disaster it
seems like in close combat kaido's
hybrid form is the most powerful since
he saves that form for last he's not
unheard-able because attacks that can
bypass his tough scales can cause harm
like advanced haki infused attacks the
opeo penomi surgical techniques and so
on after all odin did succeed in leaving
a huge lasting scar on him still there's
no doubt that this is one of the best
devil fruits of all it even makes the
sea a usual devil through weakness a
non-issue because the dragon form can
just fly over it i think that's enough
kaido for this video because we do have
others to cover but let's just say this
fruit did not disappoint in the least
next let's look at sengoku the former
fleet admiral and living legend he was
one of the major figures back during
goldie rogers time along with whitebeard
shiki and gar after time skip this dude
is 79 years old he has an especially
interesting mythical zone fruit namely
the hitohito no me model daibutsu or the
human human fruit model buddha he has
the ability to transform into a giant
gold buddha and notably back when i did
the first mythical zone video this was
the only confirmed human human mythical
zone fruit but we'll be adding two more
newly confirmed human human mythical
zone fruits to the list this time around
but back to sengoku for now during
chapter 578 at marine ford we see his
giant form launch shock waves at
blackbeard blackbeard and his crew are
shown to be rattled by the attack whited
out eyes blood and all that jazz but
obviously the attack doesn't keep
blackbeard down obviously sengoku's size
and physical power in this form are
great and although he failed to execute
ace with a punch thanks to luffy's
inflated stomach and a candle wall his
power still led to the execution
platform collapsing and that is it for
sengoku we haven't seen much of his
power in action but what we have seen
was no doubt epic definitely a power
fitting for a former fleet admiral next
up we have yamato kaido's child and
number one odin fan as us weekly manga
readers found out more or less recently
yamato also has a mythical zone fruit
namely the inuinomi model okuchi no
makami or the dog dog fruit model okuchi
no makami we're told that it is a rare
mythical wolf and that it is a guardian
spirit of wano and that makes it all the
more painful for kaido that yamato is
using it and claiming to be odin at
first it seemed like she might have
eaten it by accident but now with the
revelation that specifically zone fruits
have a will of their own in chapter 1044
it's possible that the fruit in a sense
chose yamato because her beliefs
complemented that of a guano protector
so well the fruit lets yamato turn into
a wolf god pretty much and we've seen
the cool hybrid forum clash with kaido's
own hybrid form not only is it clearly
mythical and powerful it's also very
valuable because of its symbolic value
for wano specifically it'll obviously be
easier to rule a country if their
guardian deity is supporting you rather
than challenging your authority another
hype fact is that kaido says he worked
hard to acquire that devil fruit and
whenever yonko worked hard to acquire a
specific fruit like blackbeard with the
dark dark fruit and shanks with the gomu
gomu no me it's always a sign that the
fruit is an especially big deal keep in
mind this is not just a mythical zone
but a carnivorous mythical zone making
the fruit especially well suited for
combat and it would have to be special
to allow one to repeatedly clash with
the so-called strongest creature in the
world in his op hybrid form we saw how
quickly kaido took out luffy the first
time so the fact that yamato can occupy
the yanko for so long while he's in his
strongest form is no small feat we've
also seen yamato fire a mouth blast
called namuji glacier fang add kaido
that was met with one of his own blast
breaths and the attacks canceled each
other out it's an interesting attack
name that lends a fire versus ice
dynamic to the kaido vs yamato fight
most recently she saved the day by
encasing the majority of kaido's bombs
in ice and thus preventing conjurors
fire from setting off a giant
all-encompassing explosion yamato's
mythical fruit did not disappoint and as
i've said many times before i would love
to have a mythical zone user like yamato
joined the straw hat crew and the new me
is laughing at what the old me said
because of course now i know something
the me from the old mythical zones video
didn't namely that we do have a mythical
zone user on the crew already but to
quickly wrap up with yamato first i'd
love her to join the crew but my only
concern is that it wouldn't make much
sense symbolically for the guardian
deity of wano to leave the island
especially if the will of zone fruits
will continue to be an important factor
in the story it's likely that this
mythical zone will push yamato towards
staying near wano so she can watch over
it and protect it if the need arises
anyways speaking of a mythical zone user
already on the straw hat crew it's time
to address what i've been dancing around
throughout this video yes the mythical
zone user on the straw hat crew is none
other than luffy as most of you probably
already know long story short the gomu
gomu no me is actually not a paramecia
rubber fruit but a mythical zone fruit
its actual name is the human human fruit
mythical model nika and nico was a sun
god associated with liberation so it
makes sense that when luffy awakens this
fruit his hair looks like it's made out
of flames and now we know that it turns
white in color luffy calls this awakened
form gear 5 and i gotta say it is very
reminiscent of the super saiyan form
nothing wrong with that it's not a bad
thing for it to be reminiscent of the
super saiyan form in fact it's a nice
homage to the very important dragon ball
series that paved the way for many
shonen like one piece obviously luffy's
fruit deserves its own video and i can't
do it justice here but to summarize the
gist of it it's like the most special
fruit the exact word they used to
describe it was ridiculous but i still
think special applies as far as we know
it was the only one so dangerous and
special that the government changed its
name it's associated with the sun god
dica with joy boy and now with our main
character and the last time it awakened
was more than 800 years ago so since
then the users before luffy only got to
the rubber stage that's a nice little
aspect to it because yeah luffy still
has a super special fruit but at least
he had to work hard in order to unlock
its specialness many others had this
godly fruit and never got to this point
the five elders further explained that
they attempted to get the sun god fruit
for 800 years and now once did they
succeed it actively tried to escape
their grasp and as i already explained
that type of personification makes sense
because specifically his own fruits are
said to contain a will of their own this
suggests that the fruit probably picked
luffy similarly to how i believe
yamato's fruit probably picked her it
wasn't just luffy happening to eat it it
probably called out to him on some level
so what are some of the properties of
this god fruit we know the rubber part
but it's explained that after awakening
the rubbery body of the user gains
greater physical strength and freedom it
is said by the five elders that there is
no power more ridiculous and in the
official translation we are given not
one but two exclamation marks it's
portrayed as the biggest deal and for
good reason it's also mentioned that the
rubber body lets the user fight in
whatever way he fancies bringing smiles
to the faces of the people another name
for the sun god nika we're told is also
the warrior of liberation now that's a
big deal the quote saying that the user
of the fruit can fight in whatever way
they fancy it seems to imply that luffy
is only limited by his imagination when
it comes to the way in which he fights
and the powers which he manifests i
won't go so far as to say that he can do
anything yet because some of this might
be more legend than truth but it'll be
interesting to see how accurate the
description is as the story progresses
and luffy continues to use his new
awakened powers so far we've seen luffy
use his awakened fruit to grab kaido's
dragon form like he was a mere snake toy
and pull him up to the roof he proceeded
to practically enter a toon world he
spun kaido around and slammed him into
the ground over and over again kaido's
eyes pop out like in looney tunes
suggesting that luffy can make his
opponents take on these exaggerated
characteristics not just himself and we
see that in a later chapter as luffy
blows himself up inside kaido and kaido
stretches in super unnatural ways we
also see luffy pull a popeye and summon
massive muscles all of a sudden we also
see him enter this insane god size mode
where he becomes as i previously alluded
to larger than kaido himself and can use
kaido's dragon form as a skipping rope
which was hilarious i mean if he is
strong enough to do all of this to kaido
i doubt there's any opponent he can't
lift he also rubberized the ground and
lifted it up to deflect a blast breath
showing his awakened powers can
definitely affect his surroundings so
yeah this was definitely an epic reveal
and awakening and i look forward to
seeing all of the other details that
continue to come out about luffy's new
powers since there will no doubt be more
and more details and upgrades coming out
about the form until the story ends the
other mythical human human fruit that i
have to add is the hitohito no me model
onyudo aka human human fruit mythical
model onyudo onyudo translates to big
monk and is a reference to a large monk
yokai in japanese folklore the current
user is onimaru a fox that used to be
friends with master swordsman shimotsuki
ushimaru the zorro look alike like with
chopper the fruit has given onimaru an
animal the ability to turn into a human
more or less and in his giant monk form
where he towers over zorro he can speak
as well in his humanoid form he's called
gyukimaru as you'd expect onimaru's
mythical zone comes with increased
endurance letting him make it through a
lot including arrows and even a bazooka
i sort of want to just say that all
mythical zone users have mythical
endurance since it seems like they can
bounce back after so much all the more
so now that our plot armored protagonist
was revealed to b1 as well it makes
sense that onimaru's giant size comes
with increased power as well it's also
noteworthy that yukimaru exchanged blows
with zorro in his yokai form he's not
stronger than zoro but still you need to
be pretty skilled to not get overwhelmed
immediately by our zorro so all in all
pretty impressive stuff for a fox and i
can just say that onimaru feels like a
really cool throwback to chow chow the
dog from orange town obviously oda gave
the fox more development in a mythical
zone fruit but they have similar
energies for sure they just happen to be
super protective over different things
so those are all the canon fruits and i
could stop the video right here but for
those who perfectly remember all of the
details about all of the mythical zone
users and additionally remember
everything they've read about them in
oldest question corners i do have some
bonus mythical zone fruits for you so
even you the most hardcore fans just
might learn something new about one
piece let's start the non-canon fruits
off with the batobato no me model
vampire aka the batmap fruit model
vampire this fruit gives its user
patrick redfield the ability to turn
into a you guessed it vampire this
character was designed by oda himself
and serves as the main antagonist of the
one piece unlimited world red game again
this is not in canon but according to
sengoku redfield was powerful enough to
rival the pirate king in his prime with
his unique mythical zone powers he can
sharpen his teeth and use them to you
guessed it suck the blood out of his
enemies take a second go down to the
comments and rank that vampire accent
out of 10. back to the video his victims
age quickly as a result of the blood
sucking while redfield becomes stronger
and through these means gains access to
eternal youth next up we have the
toritorinomi model nue aka the bird bird
fruit model nue this fruit was featured
in the one piece art nue a series of
artwork created for the one piece x
kyoto event in 2017 that depicts a
non-canon story of the straw hats in
wano the fruit was eaten by toratsugu a
resident of wano which is fitting
because the nue is a mythical japanese
yokai it's a chimera beast that borrows
different body parts from different
animals for instance it has the face of
a monkey the body of a tiger the mane of
a lion and a snake for a tail when
toratsugu transforms into the yokai he
has the ability to fly but is
nevertheless overpowered relatively
quickly by luffy oda himself drew the
climactic scene where luffy battles the
new way for the final mythical zone user
we turn to the same video game we
already mentioned specifically to one
piece unlimited world red again in this
video game we also find out about
inuinomi model bakedanuki literally
translated to dog dog fruit model
monster raccoon dog it allows its user
to transform into a tanooki monster and
it was eaten by get this a pen once
again oda designed the mythical zone pen
called pato and pato belongs to the
already mentioned redfield pato may not
be the most op mythical zone user but
he's definitely interesting he can use
the tip of his tail to write and
furthermore has the ability to transform
leaves into objects and people by
writing on them and that is it all 11
mythical zone users from one piece
updated video games and art exhibitions
included and their powers explained
thank you so much for staying tuned
until the end and let me know which
mythical zone you'd want it can be from
this list or you can get creative and
pick from a myth we haven't seen yet in
one piece if you did enjoy this video
and want to keep them coming the best
thing you could do is channel pyroking
within and smash that like button with
no mercy if you haven't make this video
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece videos and updates
and while you wait for the next video to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing one-piece playlist that includes
videos on all the fruits yonko warlords
and much more linked to that is in the
description and for all mythical zone
fans out there i recently came out with
a new video about the mythical zone that
i strongly believe blackbeard has i'll
put it on screen here highly recommend
that one and until next time see you
space cowboys